uh to the United States where President
Biden has warned that hurricane Ian
could be the deadliest ever recorded in
the State of Florida he said the numbers
are currently unclear but early reports
suggest what he called a substantial
loss of life the store made landfall as
one of the strongest ever to hit the US
and he's still lashing Florida with
strong winds and torrential rates
a trail of destruction after making
landfall in Florida's Southwest
hurricane Ian left flooded neighborhoods
leaving many trapped
this hospital was badly affected
evacuations in other parts further along
the Hurricane's trailer and going
Governor DeSantis called the storm
historic
we've never seen a flood event like this
we've never seen storm surge of this
magnitude and it hit an area where
there's a lot of people and a lot of
those low-lying areas and it's going to
end up doing extensive damage to a lot
of people's homes
where the storm already passed it was a
harrowing experience
it was just Relentless spinning
constantly just over us over us you hear
the metal banging against the building
it's dark you don't know what's going on
out there
others were not that lucky this could be
Florida's deadliest hurricane on record
U.S President Biden said the federal
government promised help the president
our Administration are fully committed
to offering and supplying Federal
support to the state officials and doing
everything we can to to help them both
in terms of recovery but also whatever
is necessary to ensure the folks are
safe and and out of Harm's Way
hurricane Ian has left Millions across
Florida without electricity
authorities fear even more severe damage
as the storm continues its trail of
Destruction on Florida's north eastern
coast
will carry Bob as a broadcaster for
National Public Radio she joins us from
Fort Myers in Florida which as we've
seen has also been badly hit so welcome
Carrie and what can you tell us about
the situation there right now
well the damage has truly been
catastrophic around here the Fort Myers
Beach is a town that has basically been
leveled every building seems to be gone
downtown Fort Myers is there was water
almost to the second level cars
submerged many people lost homes many
people are injured and there is just a
huge amount of damage
and President Biden warning that the
storm could be the deadliest in the
state's history
um how badly are are people being
affected what are you seeing and hearing
there
we simply don't know the extent of the
harm and the injury yet I know that more
than 500 rescues have been made in Lee
County which is where Fort Myers is and
Charlotte which is the county just North
when Rescuers get out and about they we
will know more uh the Naples City
Manager estimated 200 million dollars in
damage in that small city which is south
of us right and how has the rescue
operation been coordinated is it going
well
foreign
slowly only because they couldn't get
out until really late morning today uh
it's about 3 P.M here in Florida now uh
so they've been at it for some hours but
until the Wind and Rain died down they
couldn't get out either so people have
possibly been waiting for help and they
may be waiting a bit more
is it too soon to start talking about
reconstruction and the costs and how
that's going to work
I think it is we still have power is
still out for about 2.7 million people
in the region which is almost the entire
grid uh and authorities say that the
infrastructure has been badly damaged to
the point where they can't just run
around and reconnect things they have to
really rebuild so I don't know the full
extent but I know that it's going to
take a long time and be very uh very
deep changes right and the storm has has
weakened now uh what's being predicted
for its course
it is last I heard it's in the Atlantic
Ocean off of the East Coast of Florida
and headed for South Carolina it may
strengthen to a hurricane again but
there are still tropical storm force
winds and flooding in northeastern
Florida this evening
good talking to you thank you so much
for joining us Carrie Baba in Florida
for npl